it's a pleasure to be here I I want to
talk about something that I think you
know more about than I do which is
workflow and it's something that
statisticians let's see I want to say
it's implicit to statistics but
statisticians and statistical
practitioners don't think enough or a
lot about it so let me start with an
example this is from well this is from
our book but it's from it's a
reconstruction of a graph from a paper
that was published in 1988 in which well
at the time there was concern about
electromagnetic power lines causing
cancer there have been some
epidemiological studies finding that
kids who live near electric power lines
who are more likely to get leukemia to
jump to the end like after controlling
for a bunch of things there's not really
evidence that electric power lines cause
cancer but at the time there was a
concern in in the 80s and there is a
biological question how could this be
possible
electromagnetic like--we electromagnetic
waves and power lines are too low energy
to ionize your cells and cause you
cancer the way x-rays can and they're
too low energy to cook you the way
microwaves can and the conjecture was
that they interfered with brain
signaling because as you might know some
of your brain signals are approximately
60 Hertz so some research was done
apparently there's calcium channels are
involved in brain signaling they did
this experiment where they they killed
some chickens and oh come on it just it
was just Thanksgiving I do not not
and they broke the it was a you know
controlled experiment so they broke the
chicken brain in half and one half of
the chicken brain got the treatment the
other got the control and the treatment
was to be exposed to these magnetic
fields and the control wasn't was to not
and then they'd measured the calcium
efflux in the chicken brains took the
difference they had a lot of chickens I
got you know get the standard deviation
divided by the square root of n and
report it they did a separate experiment
at each of several thirty-eight
different experiments at each of several
frequencies of magnetic field and they
presented the results roughly like this
they gave the estimated treatment effect
and then they shaded it based on whether
it was statistically significant or not
and then when they reported their
results they so they found those three
those three things at the top were like
really really statistically significant
and a very high level like point
0:01 so they had a story for what was
happening there then they had something
that had an intermediate level of
statistical significance and they had a
story for that and then they had a
different story for the things that were
just barely statistical significant and
then another story for the ones that
weren't for convenience I'm Lea graphing
that the data as estimates plus or minus
two standard errors or one standard
error would whatever doesn't really
matter
I guess the point that I want to make
about workflow there's a saying in
statistics that anything worth doing is
worth doing over and over and over and
over and over again
statistics is is sometimes called the
science of defaults so when we develop a
statistical method we're concerned about
its statistical properties and oddly
enough one of the things that we all
have to get used to when thinking about
statistics is that even if you do
something only once you have to imagine
what would have happened had you done it
differently had it had it gone
differently and in classical statistics
this is called the sampling distribution
or the frequency
properties of your method in Bayesian
statistics it's called the population
distribution or the prior distribution
it doesn't really matter what your
philosophy is and in that's sort of the
essence of statistics or statistical
analysis to consider doing things
multiple times and you can kind of
figure out the statistical properties of
these p-values and they'll be very noisy
in fact we had this idea that every time
someone comes up with a p-value there
should be a 95% interval for the p-value
that's associated with it so like it
would say like the p-value is 0.05 and
the 95% interval it goes from 0.001 to
0.99 three you know like that actually
the 95% interval can go all the way to
one if there's a possibility that the
z-score could go on the other half so if
the p-value is 0.05 the 0.05 then the
95% interval it is roughly that so
basically I mean of course it's more
informative to look at the estimated
treatment effects but if you wanted to
do that you would do that you would you
could take these and say these are very
noisy statistics it would be a mistake
if you were as a researcher to routinely
do experiments and then have the
procedure which you do an experiment and
then you sift them based on your
p-values in order to make
classifications then that procedure will
routinely give you errors large errors
because the classifications are
extremely noisy it would be a little bit
like if you all do like cross-validation
so you have a whole bunch of different
methods and you do a cross-validation
experiment and your ten methods are all
very very close together you you know
that any of the ten could be okay you
wouldn't just pick the winner it's just
because cross-validation error is itself
just a sample statistic the thing that
people don't understand about the
p-values is that 0.001 or point two like
actually they're like within the 95%
interval either of them could easily
occur so there's very little information
I'm happening here so that's what they
did here they just pretty much got a
bunch of noise and
of course we we see that all the time
sometimes we've been told that what we
should do is have a very stringent
standard so we will set a threshold so
only the most SuperDuper statistically
significant things count but again the
problem is that the difference between
something being SuperDuper statistically
significant and just sort of kind of
middling itself is not itself
statistically significant it's still
very noisy so that's kind of a simple
idea I'm probably the most important
idea of statistics but what I want to do
is connect it to this idea of workflow
so to move us away to move us away from
the idea of doing of of looking at
things one at a time without their
context so another this is an old
example on another example I've been
talking about more recently was a couple
years ago was a study of the
effectiveness of early childhood
intervention on children that they did
an experiment on 130 children 134 year
olds in Jamaica and they half of the
kids got some sort of modest
intervention of the forms of like
leaflets and vitamins and then the other
half the mother of the child got a
weekly intervention which was supposed
to help her do better things with her
kid they were the children were followed
up 20 years later and their earnings
were recorded and it turned out that the
kids in the treatment group had 40%
higher earnings than the kids in the
control group 42% higher earnings and
that result was statistically
significant the 95% interval was from
roughly 2% to 82% so there was a
confidence interval so you know that
actually like if this is zero and this
is the standard error which is 20% the
estimate had to be at least here to be
published to be reported it there were
some degrees of freedom in the analysis
having to do with missing data which
gave the researcher is enough
flexibility that they were able to get
over here now if we were if I were to
say this is like a one-shot deal say
well this is what the data said what if
routinely we had a field I don't know
let's call it economics in which in
which what we would do is gather data
and then do what we need to get things
to be more than two standard errors away
from zero so our head drifted there then
and then publish those things and then
look at the statistical properties of
our results what we would find that we
would be systematically overestimating
effect sizes let's that's like workflow
or thinking about workflow a little bit
so today I have a few examples for you
and then I'll talk about some let's see
so I'll have a few examples and then
I'll talk about some general principles
so this was something we did a few years
ago during the World Cup the World Cup
is a is a international competition
there's a sport called soccer that
country other countries like you know
countries like Costa Rica and other
countries play and some of the best
teams in the world compete we got some
data and fit what they call in
psychometrics an item response model and
estimate the abilities of the teams I'll
show you the data that we use these are
our estimates I'll show you the data
that we used we have two data files
first we have all the games Brazil beat
Croatia 3-1 Mexico beat Cameroon 1-0 etc
then I have this
list of soccer teams this was prepared I
just pulled this off the internet from
some source some sports web page a
ranking of the teams before the before
the tournament began we use these two
pieces of information we fit a model and
stand for simplicity I'm just I've
omitted the declaration statements we
modeled the square root of the score
differential and for any given game it's
going to depend on the difference
between the two teams and then there's
an uncertainty because you know game
outcomes are are uncertain then the team
abilities follow a model a normal model
and it's a linear function of this prior
score so we rescale the prior score so
that if you're the best team I think
your score was plus one and if your uh
priori the worst team your score your
prior score is minus one so this is your
prediction and then there's this is
important because if you didn't have
this it would say that you could
perfectly predict their abilities based
on their prior score so we fit the model
to data you get estimates our hats close
to one the model seems to have converged
okay B this parameter B 0.46 B was the
coefficient on the prior score so is
positive meaning teams that were better
did better which is relief I guess and
there's some uncertainty Sigma a is the
uncertainty in the T the variation the
team abilities which say the teams don't
there's not much evidence that they very
much conditional on their prior score
and Sigma wise is that the actual game
outcome is quite uncertain especially
given that this is on the square root
scale and then we get estimates for all
the teams which we plotted so this is
all fine um now I want to talk a little
bit about workflow so a key part of this
model key question is what did this
prior information give us I'm going to
refit the model without the prior power
index
and this is what I get so let me
actually go back and tell you this story
here this is a few years ago but Brazil
was favored in the tournament as you
might remember they lost our best
estimate is still that they are one of
the better teams out there Germany won
the tournament but our estimate is that
Germany isn't necessarily the best team
because they didn't play that many games
as you go down we get teams that are
worse and I just cut this off to save
space but if you go down here you get
the teams with negative abilities and we
just centered the model around zero when
we do not include their prior ability
estimates we get something much
different now Spain was supposed to be
one of the best teams but they lost as
you might recall in the first round so
without using their prior our prior
knowledge we estimate them to be
negative and these teams down here don't
actually have negative estimated
abilities because they played so few
games now what's the point of this I my
point here is not to kind of get into
like a debate about whether we should
use that information or not of course I
would use the information I do want to
emphasize that we estimate that
coefficient B from the data so we're not
like putting in a statement that teams
that are supposed to be better do better
we're allowing that to be the case what
I really want to emphasize is that the
way we understand our models is by
fitting other models and this is
something you don't see like in this is
a key workflow thing you don't really
see in statistics textbooks I mean yes
you see people fitting model after model
after model but usually it's either to
get to the model they want like we do
this this this finally were there or as
a robustness check like here's the model
we want oh here's a bunch of other
models
robustness checks are kind of a scam in
that I've done robustness checks myself
it's the ideas you have a result that
you like and so then
what you do is you kind of perturb it a
whole bunch of different ways and say
yeah I still got that result yeah I
still got it I still got nothing changed
like it's you really don't want to use
data analysis methods whose purpose are
reassurance that's not really where you
want to be but and that's what those
things are so this is a little different
what I'm saying is I fit this model and
this makes sense I like the estimates um
but I want to understand what I want to
understand what this did
so to understand what it did I take it
out and this is useful it's part of our
workflow not really formalized though
and it's also an issue in like
programming so so we use you know github
and that sort of thing but it's kind of
difficult like you you end up having
like a deck of models like in your
directory you'll have like the model I
finally fit then you'll have simple
model model 1 model 2 normal model T
model hierarchical model you start like
giving all the models different names of
like 18 different files it's really hard
to find them so we I think actually this
is something missing like since you all
are tool builders I think we need tool
we need better workflow tools for a
statistical modeling we don't really
have them all oh so I did another thing
I took the model and I did some cross
validation so for each game I use the
model to predict the outcome of the game
and these are 95% predictive intervals
and then you have the dots or the game
outcomes now if you look at this
carefully you'll notice that more than
5% of the dots are outside the lines
that that's bad
I did like so many things I went I'd
like spent so much time debugging the
mile I tried 8 different things that
kept everything looked fine until it was
always spitting out this like I thought
well the data are discrete right because
you can't like win a game by three point
four points so like I did all sorts of
things it kept showing up I finally
found the bug which was not worth not
even interesting I divided something by
2 by oxidant somewhere in my code when I
fixed the bug then I redid it and I got
this um and this is right I mean
actually like 5% of the time they're
outside the 95% interval no you you just
it's really true like Algeria could have
beaten Germany according to the model
that's you know anything can happen in
in one giving game
um so of course this is part of workflow
too now you don't see a lot of model
checking in the statistics books I'm
partly because once you check the model
you and find a prop either you check
them all you don't find a problem or you
do if you don't find a problem who cares
if you do find a problem you're supposed
to fix it right so you don't real ever
see it's like no one comes up to you and
says let me introduce you to my first
wife you know like it's the same so we
we don't see all these like bad models
it didn't work at the model sit they
might be fine but they just didn't work
out okay I'm not saying is anything
wrong with these models but they just
they weren't not appropriate for the
situation so again like a certain amount
of workflow is is kind of hidden okay
here's another example we this is just a
fun fun example of data from an old
statistics textbook on the probability
they someone gather data on pro golfers
and they had the number of putts the
percent a percentage of putts that were
made at at each distance so most of the
three foot putts are most of the two
foot putts were made about half of the
five foot putts were made and then as
you go further they're less and less
likely to be fit sorry I didn't make
this graph in Python but
I would have if I knew how to program in
Python and didn't know are I I guess I
probably would have done that I
sometimes give this to students and say
hey fit these data and so they'll fit
the logistic regression and there you go
just for fun I want it to fit the model
from first principles so I know it's
like okay here's the ball and there's
the hall and if the angle is within the
dotted line more than half of the balls
inside the hole this is not a completely
realistic model of golf because you can
hit it too soft or too hard this is a
model right okay models that's fine you
try to hit it straight but you can't and
your inaccuracy is presumably centered
at zero with a bunch of small
independent factors which will give you
a normal distribution so this model has
one parameter which is Sigma so given
Sigma this gives you for any distance
you can figure out the probability that
the angle is small enough within some
range that it goes into the hall so
here's the stand model this is it the
probability is two times the normal
cumulative distribution function of the
arc sine ba ba-ba-ba-ba binomial data we
fit the model you can run stand from
Python but I and if I knew how to
program in Python it didn't know R I
would so that we fit so here are the
results everything seems fine i I had a
different version in the program where I
multiplied Sigma by 180 so I could see
the standard deviation is 1.5 degrees
it's estimated it's kind of ridiculous
that it's estimated at one point here's
my uncertainty it's kind of ludicrous to
say I can estimate the standard
deviation between one point five one at
one point I mean that's kind of
meaningless but within the context of
the model somebody asked me this the
other day actually they were doing an
analysis and the standard error was too
small because like they had like it was
like this kind of thing
had a ton of data on they fit a model
and they were like they didn't feel
comfortable having such a narrow
standard error and they asked me what to
do about it and I said that you should
break up your data and into chunks so I
fit the model separately for data from
each year or each golf course or each
player or whatever set up a hierarchical
model because the like you are in some
sense you are very accurately estimating
this parameter Sigma but this parameter
Sigma is the average over whatever
golfers happen to be in this data set
and whatever years and so forth so if
the standard error is too small like you
know if the standard error is too small
I've seen people do things like multiply
the standard error by square root of n
to get it bigger early just but like
really I mean you should treat it as an
opportunity obviously to do better so
here's the fitted model pretty good huh
and I just I know look at that it's a 1
parameter model but it wins well of
course this is the kind of workflow
we're used to seeing here's two models
and one of them might I don't like but
still I think it does help me understand
things a little better what's the time
oh okay okay another example I apologize
if anyone has seen these before a few
years ago someone sent me this paper in
the mail email they pointed me to it and
I think they wanted me to laugh at it
but but I liked it actually was it was a
good paper influence of Valentine's Day
and Halloween on birth time birth timing
so that paper had this beautiful graph
where they
they had the week before in the week
after and you can see there were more
births on Valentine's Day and then they
you see that the little which they are
yeah so then they had Halloween and and
the same thing and and the different
Halloween and Valentine's Day like stood
out they were statistically significant
I'm actually more natural births also
which seems kind of odd like so that the
paper had a theory that like the women
could control when the baby was coming
out I'm I'm looked doubtful but you know
there is there is selection because the
natural births I mean those of you who
studies social science know that like
selection is everywhere so the natural
births are all the births that weren't
scheduled or cesarean birth so in fact
they there's you they can be affected by
selection also so I saw these data I
mean this was pretty cool that was I was
a little concerned I wanted to UM I
wanted to look at all 366 days not just
30 days
so somebody sent me this ya know not a
lot of people born on July 4th there's
there's Valentine's Day and there's
Halloween it's sort of hard to read this
there's like a zigzagging there's a like
about 52 of those during the year this
was data from well let me do it was like
11 years or 20 years of data it was not
28 years of data so there's confounding
between day of the week and day of the
year somebody made this graph for me
which which is it's kinda kind of hated
it I can't hate it because I mean it
allows me to do things like say well I
can see there are more births in in the
summer which is sort of late summer and
early fall but I can actually see that
much better from here the time series is
much better but this is so simple like a
simple graph right the simple thing
works also this allows me to learn that
like compare the 20
first of every month but why would I
want to do that I don't think I don't
think I do
so I didn't like it but then I like this
so my collaborator aki veteran made this
graph it's a time series decomposition
using a Gaussian process model and
there's a slow trend because there were
times when babies were less common and
more common there's a fast non periodic
component because like things happen
there's weeks and months and when it's
more or less popular to have a baby
there's day of the week of that's
because fewer babies on the weekend and
even more so in more recent years
because presumably scheduled births
there is this well-known seasonal effect
that more babies are born at the end of
the summer more people are creating the
babies around here and everybody thinks
that's so funny and then finally we
estimated so we didn't actually tell the
model about Valentine's Day what we did
is we put in 369 6x we told the model
about Thanksgiving Labor Day and
Memorial Day because they float the and
the others we didn't tell them all it
just kind of discovered these things and
so you can see what's hopping so here it
here's Valentine's Day now this is
already a little bit of work flow but
let's do a little more work flow on you
we refit the having done that we refit
the model on new data that someone sent
us data from 2000 to 2014 and we fit the
same level and you can see the slow
trend the fast not periodic component
now I just want to put everything on
this scale here look everything goes
from about 50 to 120 so look at the day
of the week effects think they're about
80 or so now in more recent years it's
like 60 so there's actually very few
babies born on the weekends now and
there is the seasonal effect which looks
a little smoother than before what
after that and finally the day of the
year effect and I'm gonna go back here
you see in these days like New Year's
Independence Christmas it was eighty
birth out of a hundred so fewer people
born now it's about fifty nobody's born
on Christmas anymore
I think it's funny about nobody born and
leave it I think it would be cool would
be have a kid born on leap day but I
guess a lot of people don't like till
then they won't have a birthday it's so
cool but not for that I'm sure you all
would do it
so I just want to look at something
funny going on here let's look at this
is kind of complicated cause of
Thanksgiving let's look at the last half
of September
there's too many births there's like 5
to 10% too many births for two weeks
straight but that can't be right it
can't like it's not like they're gonna
schedule the birth I mean they don't
have that much flexibility because there
is this principle like the baby has to
come out at some point it's not yeah so
I think thinking about this like the
model that says these are like little
Delta functions little day special day
effects it's not really right like it
should be the effect should be like a
should be like a like a ringing right it
should be like if there are fewer babies
on Independence Day there should be more
before and after so the total impulse
response function is zero and we're not
we're not quite seeing that here and now
look at this
see yeah this is too high and this is
too smooth here this was I mean it's not
perfect but it's flatter and now there's
a bump here so what happened is because
this is being fit in an unconstrained
way it's going it's taking stuff out of
here and so this happens a lot in
statistics and policy analysis that you
have a constraint but you know there's a
constraint but you haven't put it into
your model because it's kind of too much
trouble to do right so I think a lot of
policy things are like that like if
people spend more in X they're spending
less on Y and you don't necessarily
integrate that into your mom you don't
always have to but it's good that
there's there extra information we have
so we haven't put that in the model but
like this is like so think of what we've
done in terms of workflow is certainly a
series of graphs and an understanding
but also fitting the model to multiple
data sets many times I've had something
where a procedure seems to work just
fine and one example and I don't think
this has ever happened to you but to me
it works fine in one example and it
doesn't work the next time I know no
one's I know everything for you just
always works and it's like there is this
curve right like first you get to work
on one example then two
three like and you know gradually you do
more and more like that's it that's how
we learn a news organization asked us
about Friday the 13th we don't well they
Friday isn't in this particular graph we
circled all the 13th so this gives us
some insight into Valentine's Day
because it's the 14th so one reason
there's extra babies on Valentine's Days
because it's taking some away from the
13th and I hadn't thought of that it was
there all along but I didn't notice well
the funny thing was look I know is right
there it was just can you believe that
so anyway we want it we want to do more
on this and of course I I do think that
once we get this working it'll be
applicable to lots of other situations
beyond beyond birthdays okay I had one
more example which I guess I'll skip it
was the here we are at Microsoft so I
was going to give the example of our
Microsoft Xbox survey where we surveyed
American we we did a political poll
using people playing the xbox and it
actually outperformed like normal
conventional telephone polls but let's
get that
yeah well I'll give you this this is
I'll tell you this this is not for
Microsoft these are a bunch of polls and
we had this was here each dots a survey
this is from the 2016 election and we're
applying the proportion who the who well
we're applying Hillary Clinton's lead in
the national poll versus the lead of
Democrats and if in the party
identification question so in the survey
you asked her you Democrat Republican
independent so there's like basically
almost a perfect correlation between the
percentage Democrats in the poll and
Hillary Clinton's lead and during what
was happening during the campaign was
that the polls were moving up and down
this diagonal line so there'd be like
bad news about Donald Trump Donald Trump
voters would stop responding to the poll
and then Hillary Clinton would have a
big big lead then bad news for Hillary
Clinton Hillary Clinton's supporters
would would stop responding to the poll
and and you go back and forth I'm not
really evidence that there is any change
in underlying opinions attitudes but
changes in who responded to the polls
which makes sense because almost nobody
responds to surveys so actually bad news
could be enough to make you not respond
to a survey it might not make you not it
might not be enough to make you not vote
we learned that but this is not from the
Xbox but we actually learned about that
from the Xbox study having done that
who's just like that thing with the 13th
like once we realize this we started
seeing the pattern everywhere so I want
to conclude with just a few thoughts
about data science workflow so first the
idea of information so it's said that
the most important aspect of a
statistical method is not what it does
with the data but what data uses and we
in our workflow we have to be aware of
what we're doing now those of us who are
trained in social science
we have this background where you have
the data matrix and you're supposed to
do something to the data matrix and
that's very old-fashioned way of
thinking and all the examples I showed
you here were always like feeding in
data from different sources
so remember the soccer example we had
two different sources of data the golf
we had two sources of data we had the
data with two sources of information we
had the data from the golf tournaments
and then we had some geometry that's
information too and similarly with with
the birthdays and and the other examples
I didn't have a chance to get through
and so we should be very aware of that
um the second is the idea of replication
and you've heard a lot about replication
recently I'm sure that a lot of things
that look good don't replicate now in
some sense the role of statistics or
mathematics in this world is to save us
the trouble of having to replicate
things that aren't going to work so
sometimes like someone will send me a
study and they'll say like like they
just they send me the paper and I read
the paper and say this is this is no
good
it's too noisy and then they'll say well
you think it wouldn't survive a
replication I say yeah I don't think it
was so they say so do you recommend that
someone do a replicated a pre-registered
replication I say no and they say why
not and I say well the same reason that
if I were in one of these like fancy
hotels on the 38th floor and having a
drink and someone came up to me kind of
drunk and explained to me that he was
Superman and could fly I would not say
to him oh here's a window please
demonstrate
I have some prior knowledge suggesting
that it's not gonna work some
theoretical knowledge so that theory
will enable me to not have to do the
experiment so similarly I mean yes like
we could replicate everything but life
is short so it probably doesn't make
sense like the study I showed you that
Leadworth the data were very noisy
I wouldn't go right back at them and say
replicate because that's kind of mean to
do that so the role the role of
statistical theory is a sort of
something we do all the time is simulate
fake data
so my recommendation to you do I have
like two more minutes okay my
recommendation the one one of the things
I've learned in my own workflow well
I'll tell you my workflow used to be
like this like I get the data I try to
fit the model I want to fit it's really
hard to feel like the program keeps
crashing I finally get to fit once it
fits I can't really interpret the result
like I just have a pile of coefficients
oh I know what to do so then I go back
and fit simpler models and secret weapon
and all sorts of things finally build up
to what I want so well obviously I
should just start by building up I
shouldn't start by trying to fit the
thing until I know what I'm doing that
that goes without saying but the other
thing is I what I've been doing lately
is every time I fit a model I simulate
fake data from the fitted model and
check that I can recover the parameters
well I can't maybe I can't recover the
parameters because things are noisy but
you know we cover them within their
uncertainty intervals so I I think it's
so worth doing I mean it's like building
this scale model now well certain
methods are so simple that theory can do
it for you but I want to be doing this
all the time I think you should be doing
this like it just should be it's
actually kind of ridiculous like people
will do it like a million dollar
experiment and there's a million dollar
experiment and there's five hundred
thousand dollars allocated to the
statistical analysis and zero dollars
allocated to like before you do the
experiment simulate fake data
we should be doing it always and we
should be doing these prototypes and one
of the one of the advantages you know
one of the advantages of a probabilistic
programming languages you can start to
do that but when it taught when you talk
about tools first and we have a lot of
tools for fitting models and we can
simulate fake data in our stand arm we
can simulate fake data using some like
standard models but we don't we haven't
really set up a great workflow for that
yet so when people want to simulate fake
data they have to kind of do it it's
like oh yeah better seemingly fake data
rent my own computer program to do that
it should be it should be automatic in
some way then of course we should be
comparing predictions to data and we
should be comparing models to each other
and I just want to emphasize these
things aren't really there like in the
statistics textbooks like there's not
much about the idea of information you
know replication is completely botched
because people seem to think that if P
is less than 0.01 or whatever that
things can replicate even though that
makes no sense there's very little fake
data simulation any fake date simulation
is whatever you can do with theory which
is which is fine but the the idea that
you would routinely do this like before
running an experiment you've simulated
first to check that you would have
enough information of course you should
do that comparing predictions there's a
little bit of model checking in
textbooks but really not enough it's not
enough part of workflow and then just
more generally this so I wouldn't say in
conclusion I wouldn't say that this is a
triumphant talk this is really a talk
saying there's a lot for you all to do
us as tool builders that you're going to
be building tools that are statistical
they're not necessarily going to be
fitting a statistical model but data
analysis data processing tools data
science tools and I and I think we have
to move away from the idea that the data
science tool is being used exactly once
to solve this particular problem they
move towards creating for people you
know
sweets that can allow problem-solving in
which building a model it's only part of
that I'm some so I hope that in you'll
be able to develop the tools that I will
be able to use yeah there any questions
I know I know you didn't get to the Xbox
study but I'm really I work at a company
that does a lot of polling and
forecasting and so like if I have a
survey and I have lots of auxiliary
variables and you know I trust my
turnout model and all of that and I want
to predict an election off surveys is
that like is that a lost cause oh well I
mean you know the polls snapshot not a
forecast there is evidence that for
things like the general election for
president there's not much changing in
attitudes so if you if you actually can
get a good snapshot of people's
attitudes now it probably is a pretty
good forecast and when you look at polls
that went wrong in 2016 it was mostly I
think as they weren't adjusting for
enough factors um so I mean things can
go wrong but I think it still makes
sense to try your best diet
my question is very simples i just
relized to note if you have worked with
crime data with crime data yeah yeah
I've worked with crime data okay so
maybe you wants me to be more specific
have you seen any pattern the just like
we say down birth rate and different
time of the years of days of the month
and have you seen any patterns
seasonality in to the crimes data and
also can have you be if you have done
that have you done somes
classifications of clothes trained in
the different type of crimes and
occurrences and the population involves
first thing is that crime the birth data
are like the cleanest data out there
they're super clean the crime data are
not so clean in fact it was funny just a
couple weeks ago I was contacted by
fact-checker for The New Yorker magazine
saying we're doing an article on someone
who's going through crime data and he
has this algorithm and can you evaluate
it so he sent to me and so where's the
algorithm he pointed me to a page and it
was like a bunch of spss code like
calling a function and I said well I
don't know what he's doing because it's
just like he's just calling his thing
like I don't know what it is but they
had a data visualization tool so I went
to the data visualization tool and
looked up the crime and I looked up
Manhattan you know because I live here
and then I looked up New York State and
the data were all like wrong because it
said like 19 it said that 90% of the
murders in New York State were happening
in New York County which just wasn't
right so the data were the very first
thing I looked at the data the data
worked no good and so I told The New
Yorker fact-checker and then a few days
later I got the New Yorker
and they had this article so it's like
what's going on so I emailed the fact
checker and said what gives and he said
I'll get back to you on that I have a
student who looked at the well this is
not murder he was looking at like
ticketing and and you know they they
they do give more tickets near the end
of the month and and there's a lot okay
the short answer is yeah there is just a
lot I think that could be learned from
all sorts of data sales data a crime
data that's why we want to develop these
tools the the birthday is just a
super-clean example that everybody can
relate to but we're we're hoping that
once we have it out there people can do
other things too
what's the okay the last question what's
the network of models by the network of
models I mean well there's like you
could think of a ladder of model so like
I fit a simple model than a more
complicated model but then really you
can think of models as living in a space
so when I start with a simple model then
build up to a complex of its let's
suppose I can imagine I have like a
calculus of models like I can do it by I
can add a predictor to a model I can
make a coefficient vary by group I can
add an interaction so to get from here
to here I could add them like first add
variable a then variable B then variable
C or I could add C then a then B like
the different so the model different I'm
imagining like a graph in which each
node on the graph is a model and an edge
means the two models differ by only one
thing and so I'm thinking of like a
model visualization tool in which I can
fit models along the graph and then
visualize them by comparing and it's
something we do like in regression
models if you add one predictor but I
feel like it's something that we should
think about more generally and again if
you look in the textbooks we just talked
about dealing with models one at a time
sometimes model comparison you know
which model averaging which model wins
in a you know cross validation contest
but not the idea of these models all
existing as a way for us to understand
that the data
so enjoy the rest of your conference
[Applause]